hey i'm rachel and this is my best ever
vegan burger
so i wanted to create something that is
like juicy and meaty and really
replicates that like juicy texture of a
burger so to create the texture of this
burger i wanted to make it as meaty as
possible so i added things like
mushrooms um black beans
i added the vital weakling was super
important and i also added soy sauce
which you know always like lends a
really nice like umami type flavor and
this burger is a little bit of extra
work it's not something i'm gonna make
every single
week
or even every month but when you do make
it for like a special occasion if you're
having friends over you're going to a
barbecue and you really want to like
impress your friends
i would say it's definitely worth the
effort and give it a try after i made
this burger i gave it to a bunch of my
co-workers to try and they were
blown away by the texture of it and they
were like this is crazy this tastes i
mean it's like clearly it's not meat but
it tastes a lot like me it mimics meat
in the texture in the color in the taste
the beets are really important because
they give the burger that pink bloody
color
and it's actually what beyond meat uses
in their burgers to give it the same
kind of bloody color so if you don't
have access to the impossible burger or
the beyond burger definitely give this
recipe a try because i think it's one of
the closest
recipes to those kinds of burgers so i
did a lot of research when developing
this recipe and i found to get that
really like chewy meaty texture vital
wheat gluten was a really crucial
ingredient because vital wheat gluten is
what you find in a lot of like meat
substitutes that you buy at the store
and it just gives it that chewy meaty
consistency that is what makes meat
taste like meat if you're looking for a
gluten-free option taking out the vital
wheat gluten is going to give you a very
different texture
but
i would say it's definitely worth it in
terms of making something that's really
going to replicate that texture and
consistency of meat
[Music]
i also
slathered this burger in barbecue sauce
because everything tastes better in
barbecue sauce
and i
put some vegan cheese on it which i
highly recommend so the barbecue sauce
also just takes it to the next level and
makes you feel like you're eating a
burger even more
i tried a bunch of different variations
of this burger
and i found that just the combination of
mushrooms brown rice vital wheat gluten
black beans
gave it like the perfect texture and
consistency it wasn't too much like a
veggie patty it was more like the
consistency of beef i haven't made this
burger now in over a year and now it's
making me really want to eat it again
and make it again so
definitely try it out